في ثمانيه اسابيع اذا مشاهدينا يمكن ان
تستصغر النساء او ان تصغر لخمس سنوات
كامله تخيلوا والسر في نمط الحياه كم شهر
كم شهر سبع سنوات هذا البحث هذا البحث
الجديد نشرته مجلات
حيث اظهر ان تغيير النظام الغذائي ونظام
النوم مع تمارين الرياضيه وتمارين استرخاء
ربما يكون جيدا لعكس عمليه الشيخوخه بس
للنساء
هل البحث اجري على ست سيدات
تراوحت 46 و 65 عاما خضعنا لانظمه معينه
في الحياه خلال هذه المده المفاجاه ان
اختبارات الدم التي
تبعت في البحث اظهرت ان العمر البيولوجي
لهن انخفض لما يصل لاحد عشر عاما بمتوسط
انخفاض
4.6 لكل سيده منهن لكن ما هذه التوليفه
راح نتابعها بعد قليل مع لميس بس بدي الفت
عنايه السيدات الجميلات بانه عمرهم
البيولوجي اللي بيصغر خمس سنين مش
بالضروره هذا الكلام يبين على ملامحهم
عمليه تجميل موجوده خلينا نشوف لميس شو
راح تقول
اذا باحثون في جامعه باستن و فيرجينيا
والى نويت كتبوا اننا سبب في انخفاض العمر
البيولوجي ربما يعزى لاليات العمر
الاساسيه لكن ما هي خطه التجربه طلب من
السيدات تناول الخضروات وبذور اليقطين
وبذور دوار الشمس والشمندر ومكملات الكبد
والبيض بنسب معينه كما طلب منهم تناول
حصتين يوميا من مكونات المثيب ومنها التوت
البري والثوم والشاي الاخضر والكركم وطلب
ايضا تغييرات بنمط الحياه كتناول
البروبايتك وشرب الماء والرياضه لنصف ساعه
على الاقل والتدرب على التنفس والنوم
لثماني ساعات على الاقل وصيام 12 ساعه عن
الطعام بين الوجبه والاخرى في النهايه اكد
الباحثون انه رغم عدم الالتزام الكامل من
النساء لكن شوهدت تحسينات في العمر
البيولوجي بينهن بمعدل
82% من الوقت
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات